since you are enrolled in this course
let's assume that you have decided on or
perhaps are already engaged in a
managerial or professional career and
that you are developing or have already
developed the knowledge and skills
necessary to do the job that's great but
don't stop there experts agree that it
will take a special set of competencies
to succeed in tomorrow's organizations
which will be even more globalised
digitized collaborative and agile than
those we see today many have written on
this topic one of the best sources we
think is a small monograph published by
the Institute of the future titled
future of work skills 2020 here is a
brief synopsis of the 10 competencies
that the Institute suggests will be
essential for your career success in the
years ahead first
relating to globalization the Institute
stresses the need for cross-cultural
competency which has a couple of key
components one is the ability to work
effectively with those from other
cultures
perhaps in teams made up of many
different nationalities
and the other is the ability to work
effectively outside of your native land
and while most business probably will
continue to be conducted in English it
certainly wouldn't hurt to have a
familiarity with other languages as well
turning to the circle labeled
digitization we see that there are four
key competencies involved one is sense
making the future will be all about mass
data will be even more inundated than we
are now so it will be necessary to have
the capacity to work through tons of
information and see the big picture will
have to be critical thinkers but we also
have
to keep in mind that technology isn't
good for everything so we need to
develop the capacity to decide when to
rely on computers for assistance and
answers and just as important when not
to the second competency in this area is
computational thinking this includes
developing a basic understanding of
computer programming and simulation
modeling it doesn't mean that we all
have to become computer geeks in the era
of big data we can rely on specially
trained data scientists to do the heavy
lifting but the rest of us will need to
know enough about what the experts are
doing to be actively involved in the
process in two ways one is on the front
end to frame questions and problems in
ways that the data scientists can
analyze a model and two on the back end
to be the ones who interpret the results
and come up with value-added answers in
solutions third in this context there is
the issue of new media literacy here the
references to becoming expert in the use
of social media tools internets blogs
podcasts videos and so forth in the
future many folks will be working
remotely and will be called upon to
create and share content through these
technologies and to do so in ways that
not only help solve complex problems but
also engage in persuade our colleagues
and other important people such as
customers and clients finally in this
area is cognitive load management in
tomorrow's world it will be very easy to
get overwhelmed by the mass of
information that's bound to come our way
we need to learn how to avoid this how
to evaluate rank and tag content so that
we keep our eyes on what's really
important and let the rest go somewhat
ironically computer programs are already
available
to help with this they have the ability
to sense when we are becoming overloaded
or tired and then to automatically
intervene to slow down or simplify the
flow of information we're getting third
let's turn to the issue of collaboration
one essential competency here is social
intelligence this refers to the ability
to connect with others in an emotional
and deeply personal way to quickly
assess the feelings of others and then
adapt our words tone and gestures
accordingly everyone agrees that this is
a uniquely human competency that so far
at least gives us a leg up on robots
further the Institute talks about
virtual collaboration meaning the
ability to work effectively with and
eventually perhaps lead teammates we may
never meet or even see in person this
involves becoming really good at turning
in-house networks and new media into
what some call social watercoolers
important tools helping to enhance a
sense of camaraderie and social presence
among colleagues who are all over the
map online gamers already have a leg up
on developing this competency since this
is in large part what they are learning
to do and finally let's consider agility
which really is the capacity to be
comfortable with change three
competencies are stressed here one is
novel and adaptive thinking in a world
of rapid change it is essential that we
never let the tried-and-true get in the
way of being open to new ways of doing
things in the future all of us will be
expected to keep our eyes on
developments that are going on in the
world so that we can anticipate upcoming
challenges and most important beyond the
leading edge of developing unique and
creative ideas and solutions to deal
with
these challenges in real time second the
Institute talks about design mindset
this is closely related to novel and
adaptive thinking it refers to being
super familiar with our work situation
so that we can see when changes need to
be made but even more important it
refers to having the ability to make
useful recommendations for redesigning
the work environment as well as the
processes and procedures being used to
get the work done and then there is what
the Institute calls transdisciplinarity
which is a big word for a simple idea in
the future the ideal worker will be
t-shaped that is deeply expert in one or
more disciplines which is the vertical
part of the T but also knowledgeable
about and comfortable with many other
disciplines the horizontal part of the T
in other words what's your world class
at one thing make sure you keep right on
learning about a lot of other things
success in the future will depend on our
willingness and ability to keep growing
and developing to become more global in
our thinking more comfortable with the
digitization of everything ever better
at collaborating with colleagues and
others and above all staying deeply
committed to being adaptive lifelong
learners